the strait of hormuz is now the most
militarized stretch of water in the
world commercially it is also one of the
busiest American and British warships
are now escorting cargo vessels through
the Strait every single day we traveled
with HMS Mont Rose when she picked up
three tankers heading towards Dubai
in Montrose's operations room they track
every ship in the area and watch out for
incoming Iranian fast boats the Iranian
Revolutionary Guards Navy hides many of
its boats behind some of the little
islands dotted around the region on this
occasion we are being watched and
followed by an Iranian drone overhead
the two sides interact every day at
times has got Harry on July the 10th
Iranian gunboats tried to board a UK
flag tanker the British heritage HMS
Montrose was nearby and she intervened
they were driving on us pretty quickly
and there are multiple small craft and
so are key out but it was just making
sure that we can block them in whatever
way possible so that if we needed to we
had them weapon arcs to engage if we if
we were required to do that shots
weren't fired that evening but it was a
close-run thing my mission was to
protect British shipping so I knew there
was no way there's Iranian gunboats
we're gonna go aboard that ship that
night so as I turned up 150 yards of a
port quarter all my weapons systems were
trained on to them to let them know that
quite frankly I was in a legal position
to ensure they weren't gonna go on board
and thankfully we were able to find a
compromise where we could deescalate a
situation but yeah I won't lie I was
pretty close nine days later the Stenner
Impero was successfully captured the
ship and her crew remain in an Iranian
port it has now been revealed as well
that the Iranian Navy and Revolutionary
Guard were specifically asking
commercial ships around that time if
they had any British crew on board they
were deliberately targeting Britain and
its commercial shipping interests
the UK government is now considering
sending drones to the region these
waters are as important as they are
dangerous and Britain has put itself
right in the center of this crisis
alistair bungle Sky News in the Gulf